У наступні кілька років на Україну чекають непрості часи,
попереджає прем’єр-міністр Олексій Гончарук.
За його словами, уряду доведеться віддавати рекордні борги.
На їхнє погашення, за підрахунками Гончарука, 2020 року
піде майже кожна третя гривня.
Що таке державний борг, наскільки це небезпечно для країни
і хто є найбільшим боржником у світі?
Державний борг - це загальна сума боргів держави,
які виникають в результаті  запозичень.
Станом на вересень цього року, за даними Міністерства фінансів,
державний борг України становив
майже 82 мільярди американських доларів.
Якщо поділити цей борг на все населення України,
яке нині становить близько 42 мільйонів,
кожен українець умовно винен близько 2 тисяч доларів.
Основними міжнародними кредиторами Києва, зокрема,
є МВФ, Світовий банк та ЄС.
І найближчі роки мають стати піковими для України у погашенні боргів.
Лише цього року Київ, за даними Мінфіну,
мав сплатити кредиторам 417 млрд гривень,
у перерахунку - це понад 14 млрд доларів.
Боргова політика України - це, по суті, замкнене коло,
адже Київ гасить борги, здебільшого, за рахунок нових кредитів.
Те, що попередні українські уряди зверталися за допомогою до міжнародних кредиторів,
економісти оцінюють позитивно.
Як і те, що нині країна має борг у співвідношенні
приблизно 50% до ВВП.
Дивини у цьому немає, адже чимало інших країн та компаній
так само рефінансують свої борги
за рахунок нових запозичень, кажуть оглядачі.
Проте наголошують - для країни важливо припинити жити в борг
і зберегти тенденцію до подальшого зниження заборгованості.
Власне, це обіцяє зробити новий уряд.
Так само важливо, аби запозичення були за нижчими ставками.
Нині через низький кредитний рейтинг
Україна витрачає на погашення відсотків за боргами
майже 10% видатків державного бюджету.
У підвищенні рейтингу країні може допомогти
співпраця з Міжнародним валютним фондом,
адже його присутність в Україні є для кредиторів своєрідним гарантом
того, що країна рухатиметься до економічного зростання шляхом реформ.
Найбільший держборг у світі, за даними МВФ,
має Японія  - 237,5% ВВП.
Таким чином, аби віддати запозичене,
країні треба працювати майже два з половиною роки,
абсолютно нічого не витрачаючи.
Це рекордний показник для країни,
причому він тримається на цьому рівні вже кілька років поспіль.
Втім, цей факт не заважає Японії бути третьою за величиною економікою світу.
Серед інших розвинутих країн, які опинилися
у топ 10 світових лідерів за величиною державного боргу -
Греція, Італія та США.
Державний борг має і Німеччина -
на кінець 2018 року він знизився на 52 млрд
і сягнув двох трильйонів євро.
По відношенню до валового внутрішнього продукту - це 56,9%  ВВП.
І у цьому сенсі у ФРН з Україною, яка має 62%,
схожі показники. Щоправда, вже кілька років
Берлін запозичень не робить, а з 2017 року
так званий "борговий годинник" Німеччини
вперше за 22 роки свого існування пішов у зворотній бік.
Тож щосекунди державний борг ФРН
почав скорочуватися на 78 євро.